welcome to the david pakman show i am
farron cousins from ring of fire here
with you once again we've got a
phenomenal show coming up today
obviously we've got to talk about
trump's lawsuit against the doj
and the revelation that there were 700
pages of classified documents retrieved
so far this year from mar-a-lago we've
got two of the individuals who
were plotting to kidnap
um governor gretchen whitmer from
michigan they have been convicted we've
got don jr excusing his father's actions
we've got alex jones walking back his
endorsement of ron desantis all kinds of
things
coming up on today's show so
let's jump right in obviously
one of the bigger things that happened
early this week
is the fact that donald trump
not only filed a lawsuit against the doj
seeking a special master
to go through the documents make sure
there's nothing privileged in there
but also in the filing
it appears that his lawyers actually
admitted
that he did the things that of course he
is being accused of
right here twice in the document
meaning the you know lawsuit and the
other documents that have come to light
trump admits he took government
documents which is illegal under the
espionage act and the presidential
records act
huh
you know i'm not a lawyer i work with
lawyers i i
am the editor of a legal magazine but i
gotta tell you usually when lawyers file
motions
they don't admit
to the crimes that their clients have
been accused of and
yet right there clear as day
there's two separate times where his
lawyers admit yes
um we had the documents
uh the fbi at one point told us to
secure them a little bit better so
donald trump said put a second lock on
the door
that that's in the document
and then of course they admitted it
again when they said if the fbi you know
all they had to do was come ask we would
have
you know given them the things that they
were after so you're admitting he did it
and we know from last week of course
that
reports came out saying donald trump is
unable
to attract decent lawyers
one because they don't want to tie their
name to it because they know how
unpredictable trump is and if he does
something stupid the lawyer gets blamed
for it they don't want to be a part of
that and also they're afraid they're
never going to get paid if they do legal
work for him so donald trump of course
is left with what i like to call the
bottom of the barrel
not you know what that's not even fair
to barrels okay these are not lawyers
from the bottom of the barrel he had to
tip the barrel over
and dig down a couple of feet
to find legal minds
horrible enough
to admit in their own filings
that yeah i mean he did it
but is it always bad if he does it is is
it always a crime
but all that aside the lawsuit itself uh
depending on who you ask
is either going to succeed or fail and i
know that's a very weird thing to say
but again it depends on which legal
expert you're talking to you're reading
or you're seeing you know their massive
threads on twitter explaining this
because everybody seems to have a
different thought
on what is happening here
a lot of them say that this lawsuit well
pretty much all of them say the lawsuit
is just an effort to stall right that's
a given we understand that he's stalling
the real question becomes whether or not
the lawsuit itself can be successful
that's where the divide happens
because some legal experts and i'm
talking about all the people these are
all people on the left
some say
it's an absolute farce and it has no
chance of being successful because
the special master would be appointed if
they believed some of the retrieved
materials 700 pages of classified
documents
were privileged
and that is where another dichotomy
breaks down so
if it's attorney-client privilege
then a special master would in this
particular instance be warranted under
most circumstances
not necessarily all
right if they're documents that trump
and his lawyer are discussing committing
crimes together
outside of what he's being represented
for then no that would not fall under
attorney-client privilege
if it is donald trump communicating with
his lawyer about legal actions things
like that that is privileged you can't
have those
the other kind of privilege
is executive privilege
which of course we have heard donald
trump say some of these things are
executive privilege
and
that's not going to fly you're not going
to get a special master because you say
these things are covered under executive
privilege
there's one person on the planet
who has the authority
to determine whether or not something is
covered under executive privilege that
person right now
is president joe biden
so if biden were to come out and say
none of these are executive privilege
then guess what
none of them are executive privilege
if he doesn't do that and trump did
claim privilege over some of them they
would still have that executive
privilege distinction until
the next person in line whoever that
president will be if it's biden now or
anybody else down the road takes it away
that's how the executive privilege works
once it's there it is there and it can
transfer from administration to
administration
but once you leave office it's out of
your control
so if the next person in line says no
it's not covered then it's not covered
and then of course you would not get a
special master
having said all of that
let me say this because again depending
on what kind of privilege it may or may
not take effect depending on what's in
the privileged it may or may not take
effect
any of that i don't care
i'm in favor of the special master
and there's one very specific and i feel
it's a good reason
for everybody to say you know what we'll
do the special master thing
give trump what he wants right
now because he's making a big deal of
this
so if he gets that special master
all of his followers are going to look
at it and say okay good we have
oversight
and then if you find the crimes
you know if well the having the
documents themselves was the crime um if
you find it is what you think it is and
you can indict him
having that special master there
it's not going to convince trump he'll
then attack the special master it's not
going to convince the maga hat wearing
crowd that everything was legitimate but
what it will do is it will convince all
of those republicans who are right now
on the fence they don't know whether or
not to support what's happening or to be
against it
those are the people that are going to
say well
there was a special master
they had the oversight trump they gave
trump what he wanted
and it still came to that conclusion
so i guess this was real
i guess this was legitimate
i'm not even saying folks that you're
going to have a large number of people
who who do that
but even if you have a handful of them
that's more than you've got right now
so why not just do it yeah is it gonna
slow things down a little bit sure
but if you go ahead and agree and give
in to the demands of this lawsuit which
i am typically against giving in to any
demands of these right-wingers but if
you do it now you're going to avoid a
lengthy court process where nothing's
going to be able to happen in the
interim
so agree to it today get the special
master then start going through the
documents you save yourself a lot of
time that way
trump doesn't get to stall it but for
more than what a week
and he gets what he wants
and some folks out there might view this
a little bit more legitimately than they
already were
that's why i think the special master
is a good idea i do think it's something
that the doj
needs to entertain
it's not obviously out of the realm of
possibility it happens all the time in
criminal investigations just do it
give this thing even more legitimacy is
what i say
take away one of donald trump's biggest
talking points he'll still use it
but it's not going to be as effective
against as many people
if you just do do what he wants right
now
and reap the benefits later
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below